movie lovers i'm jan and today we're
taking a deep dive into the ending of
season five part one to explain the
daddy of all get-togethers what the hell
michael's really up to
whether a demon can actually get a soul
plus predictions and theories for part
two and
season six just before we begin many
thanks to the sponsor of this video raid
shadow legends
we will of course be talking spoilers so
take care if you're not all caught up
michael's elaborate plan to ruin his
brother's life appears to be working by
the end of part one he's not only turned
maize against lucifer but he's triggered
a menadiel's fears to spiral out of
control causing time to freeze
and as the battle between team lucifer
and team michael comes to a head
in the very final moments of the part
one finale god arrives to intervene
that's enough children you know i hate
it when you fight
lucy fans have been wondering when god
would finally turn up on the show and
given the first episode of the second
part of season five is called family
dinner we can expect to see some
interesting family dynamics between god
lucifer michael and amena deal and
perhaps lucifer's other siblings remy
and azrael will also make an appearance
lucifer's family reunion in the next
episode is bound to relate
back to the moment in season five's
first episode when lucy takes lee to see
his parents house where they're
celebrating his sister's baby shower
lee says he can't go in to see them
because he's ashamed of what they think
of him
and lucifer proceeds to berate him
sooner or later you are going to
disappoint them all over again
so you'd rather stay away for all
eternity as lee points out and lucifer
soon realizes this situation
isn't just about lee in fact it reveals
lucy's feelings about how he relates to
his own family
this isn't just about me is it whose
hell is this anyway with lucifer's dad
arriving on the scene
lucifer will finally have to confront
his own feelings of shame towards his
celestial family it'll be interesting to
see if he continues to feel guilty for
his rebellion or if he can rejoin his
family
although lucifer previously said in
season 4 that he was lying to himself
about god manipulating everything in his
life
faced with his father now will any of
these old feelings resurface
if you mean his plan to continually
manipulate and control me then agreed
also will lucifer confront god over his
mother's claims that god wanted to
destroy
lucy after the rebellion i asked him to
send you to hell instead and if the
goddess was manipulating lucifer about
that
it'll be intriguing to hear god's
version of events after all
in the alternate universe bonus episode
god said that a parent just wants what's
best for their child
but of course michael will be at the
family reunion too
and we know from a mena deal that
michael has positioned himself as god's
only trusted advisor to the point that
no other being in heaven can speak to
god
he is stronger than you think lucy
michael's become
untouchable in the silver city so what
is michael's grand plan and what's he
really up to
well when michael explained to mays why
he came to earth he said he was annoyed
at the praise lucifer was getting from
all the other angels after he returned
to hell voluntarily then raphael
starts going off about how lucifer's
grown and then pretty soon all i hear
is lucifer lucifer lucifer michael's
jealous that lucy is getting kudos for
doing what he views as the bare minimum
fulfilling his basic role
something he'd previously been shirking
michael also appears to be threatened by
his twin brother's growing maturity and
ability to sacrifice his own happiness
in la
in order to save those he cares for and
do his duty as ruler of hell
if god believes that lucifer has
redeemed himself for his rebellion then
michael's favored position in heaven
sitting at god's right hand
may be in danger because of his
inferiority complex in relation to his
twin
michael has been constantly plotting to
have lucifer make decisions that will
make him look unworthy in god's eyes
all the while raising his own status in
the silver city
as a melodyl pointed out you're
terrified that lucifer is better than
you that he'll always
be better than you according to michael
he claims he's been secretly planting
ideas in lucifer's mind from starting an
uprising against god to his antics in
the garden of eden
michael even says he was responsible for
giving lucy the idea to abandon his
responsibilities in hell to come to los
angeles of course given michael's
tendency to tell
lies it's possible that his claims of
controlling lucifer's actions are
actually false
and that what he's really doing by
telling his brother that he's been
playing him all this time is preying on
lucy's fears
because if there's one thing we know
about lucifer is that he does not like
to feel that he's being manipulated
another part of michael's plan has been
to exploit chloe's fears around her
relationship with lucifer
after michael abducts chloe he exposes
her concern that lucifer hasn't said the
exact words i love you to her something
that begins to prey on her mind
in particular given that earlier ella
was raving about pete's i love meatloaf
line how long did it take lucifer to say
i love you michael
also tries to worry chloe about
lucifer's newfound invincibility when
he's with her him choosing to be
vulnerable around you it actually meant
something because you do know that we
angels we self-actualize right
so when chloe's reunited with lucifer
she wonders whether subconsciously he's
pushing her away
and if his new invulnerability around
her means he's choosing not to be
vulnerable with her
now michael has obviously amplified
chloe's fear but i think it's evident
that lucifer does love her because he
finally attempts to tell her how he
feels
no just chloe i
i'll lucy may have been cut off by a
menadil
accidentally freezing time but the
crucial point to note here is that
lucifer used chloe's real name rather
than detective
because although he rarely uses her true
name when he does it signals his true
feelings towards her my first love was
never eve
it was you chloe on top of that lucifer
was desperate to find chloe when she
disappeared in the final episode making
it clear that he does
love her deeply now i've got a lot more
details to discuss about lucifer's new
found in vulnerability and the weird
mojo swapping going on between him
and chloe that's all in a separate video
and i'll add a card here and a link in
the video description as soon as it's
ready
when it comes to maze she's been through
a rough time so far
in season five leading her to switch
allegiance from team lucifer to team
michael
after he promises he'll get her the soul
she's been longing for
at the start of the fifth season she's
already mad at lucifer for going down to
hell without her and
adding to her abandonment issues a chloe
who splits up their detective
partnership
eve who left her at the end of season
four and then her mother lilith who dies
a few days after she sees her again and
before
mays can really tell her how she feels
mays believes her lack of a soul is
responsible for her loneliness and
blames lilith for that
it was her stupid idea to have soulless
offspring making it her stupid fault
that i
am doomed to be alone forever and when
she asks lucifer if he's heard of a
demon getting a soul he enrages her with
his dismissive attitude even after she
points out that nobody heard of the
devil falling in love before
or of an angel and a human having a baby
together there's a first for everything
right oh that's different we're angels
you're just a
demon the topic of maze and demons not
having a soul has come up previously
in particular in the maze focused
episode mr and mrs mazakin smith
when i die that's it maze out this
season
presenting himself as a friend to maize
michael offers her a soul which is what
she thinks she wants
although given his tendency for lying
and manipulating that's likely to turn
out to be a ruse of sorts
instead what i think could be important
to resolving maize's existential dilemma
is lucifer's ring which her mother
lilith gave him and which maize was
staring at
in the final episode we learned in the
noir episode that lilith gave up her
immortality when she blew what looked
like perhaps her own
soul or essence into the ring the ring
also contains a stone from the garden of
eden and so i think it could play a part
in may's acquiring a soul or something
else that will make her feel complete
after all as a menadil told her i don't
know if a soul
is what you need to feel whole but i do
know this
if anyone is going to find what they're
looking for it's you
massacre perhaps just like lucifer and
amena deal will learn that maize has the
ability to self-actualize
and with the help of her mother's ring
she will come to believe that she isn't
just a soulless demon after all
like dorothy with her shoes in the
wizard of oz maize has always had the
power
she just had to learn it for herself a
big reveal at the end of season 5 is
that amena deal and linda's baby boy
charlie appears to be mortal and not
half angel as everyone had previously
assumed in season 4.
this could somehow be a trick by michael
but charlie does get frozen in time
together with all the other humans in
the finale
and he also got a fever which turned out
to be a cold something that in theory
shouldn't happen to a part celestial
charlie being an ordinary human does tie
in with a little running gag throughout
the fifth season about the baby's
parents being over-optimistic about the
extent of his abilities
linda for example has arranged
everything from japanese language
classes to art appreciation events for
the two-month-old baby and she's
convinced he can even identify
elements on the periodic table and a
menadil tells dany thought charlie had
some kind of super strength but then
discovered he couldn't even hold up his
rattle
this could all tie back to lucifer's
theory in season 4 that explained how a
menadil had been able to conceive a
child with linda in the first place
when you lost your wings you became as
mortal as it gets
maybe you became more human than you
realize perhaps the menadil was so human
when charlie was conceived that the baby
never inherited any of his father's
celestial powers
but there could be something else at
play when it comes to charlie's human
versus celestial nature and it relates
to an intriguing incident in season
three
in the episode all about her amena deal
visits the doctor after getting some
cold and flu-like symptoms
a menadil says he's never had a human
illness but then the doctor tells him he
has chlamydia
later arnie discovers the diagnosis was
a false positive
the reason for the test results coming
back wrong was never really explained
but it seems reasonable to think it's
something to do with him being an
angel and not human and i think
something similar happened to charlie
when he ran a fever which the doctor
diagnosed as a normal human cold
something about his half angel half
human nature is likely at the root of it
and i expect we'll get an explanation in
the second half of season five
now there are another eight episodes
still to come in the second part of
season five
and there's a sixth and final season
after that and i'll be going in depth
with more theories for those in an
upcoming video season 5 was originally
expected to be the end of the show which
means that the 16th episode would have
wrapped up
all of the series character arcs in a
montage of sorts what's going to happen
instead now is that the sixth season
will dive deeper into each character's
ending
according to amy garcia who plays ella
we may be getting a full episode for
each character in the final season to
see in detail where
each of them ends up the ending then
will still be the same as the original
ending for season five but it will just
be extended over a full season
and while we wait for what we hope will
be an awesome final one and a half
seasons of lucifer
why not check out the epic fantasy world
of raid shadow legends
if you're like me you've probably heard
about the game already but may not have
gotten around to giving it a try yet
well it's one of the most immersive
gaming experiences you can find for your
mobile device and pc
with a dark fantasy feel and stunningly
rendered 3d characters
and on top of that it's completely free
to play
there are hundreds of champions to
choose from and tons of artifacts to
hunt for
to customize and make your own unique
band of heroes
the dungeon boss battles in the game are
spectacular and as you try out different
champion and warrior combos you'll soon
learn their strengths and weaknesses
the best way i've found to upgrade your
warriors is through farming the campaign
to gain new rewards so you can quickly
level up
and if you're into pvp the arena is a
great place where you can test your
champions against any of the million
plus players from around the world
there are also huge weekly rewards for
winning the arena battles and bonuses
for climbing the tiers
on top of that right now raid are hard
at work adding loads of new updates to
the game
such as champion fragments which lets
you summon awesome champions like jordan
there's also a new bazaar where you can
acquire high value items with the gold
bars you win in the tag arena
and the game just extended the rewards
you get for daily
logins to an amazing 270 days
you'll even be able to get entire new
champions for free
just by logging in so don't miss out on
a very special offer we've got for all
new players
click on the special links in the video
description to get an incredible 200 000
silver and this totally badass champion
grinner from the undead hordes
completely free
after you've installed the game you'll
find the rewards in your inbox here
don't forget you can only get these
bonuses by clicking on the links below
the offer runs for the next 30 days only
so don't delay and install raid shadow
legends today
so what do you think of season 5 so far
and do you have any theories on what
will happen now god's arrived or ideas
for season six
leave your thoughts in the comments
below tap left to watch my next loose of
a video with everything you missed in
season 5
or tap right for another video you're
sure to like and if you enjoyed this a
thumbs up and a share
are hugely appreciated thanks for
watching and see you next time yupikai
movie lovers